[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight in case you weren't invited the
White House Correspondents Dinner took
place over the weekend for the third
year in a row Donald Trump was invited
but took a pass and didn't show up that
has never happened in the long history
of the dinner presidents always show up
they always throw in a tuxedo and head
downtown to suck up to the White House
Correspondents Association they don't
want to do that they hate going every
one of them all presidents deeply
despise the news media but they make
themselves go they have no choice it's a
hostage situation
if you blow off the dinner the press
will punish you guaranteed they won't
admit it of course they won't say it's
personal they'll make up some story here
for example is Jeff Zucker spokesman
claiming that not going to a media
dinner is the same as attacking the
media say what you will about the press
this is an event that honors to the
First Amendment yes that's what it's
about it's an awards dinner and a
fundraiser in the past presidents have
always shown up even if they were angry
at the press at any given time it's yet
another example of what we're seeing
this administration's attack against the
media it takes many forms one form is
the president having a rally this
Saturday instead of attending the dinner
don't people are so self-confident have
you noticed that it's almost like
there's a self-esteem competence reverse
access I think that's real anyway
they're telling us that going to your
own event instead of our event is a form
of harassment you know it's not
harassment according to CNN spying on
former Fox reporter James Rosen and his
parents because you don't like what he's
covering the Obama administration
actually did that and then Obama went to
eight separate White House
Correspondents Association dinners
nobody ever denounced him as immoral
Obama hated reporters by the way most
people do hate reporters for good reason
but reporters loved him back anyway they
agreed with this politics that's what
matters
watch what happens when they don't agree
with your politics I still separate my
career into the period before February
of 2017 and what came afterwards and
that's because February 2017 is when the
president
at the United States called us the
enemies of the people I felt it was time
that we reset this dinner and put the
focus a little more squarely on on
journalism and a little more squarely on
the First Amendment a little more on the
people the men and women who helped to
hold the most powerful political
institution in American life to account
ladies and gentlemen to the First
Amendment now I'm delighted to make a
spirited case tonight for the First
Amendment we now have to fight hard for
basic truths we once took for granted
like every future President Washington
felt maligned and misunderstood by the
press but he never generalized that into
a vendetta against the institution I
think you're doing noble work to
preserve democracy at a time when a
rising tide of misinformation
masquerading as news threatens to make a
mockery of the First Amendment Donald
Trump is not the first and won't be the
last American president to create
jitters about the First Amendment well
but it's happening today is perhaps even
more insidious a relentless campaign
against the very credibility of the news
media this is a glorious tradition
you folks are part of it and we can't
have politicians trampling on it with
impunity people are doubting the news
media that's wrong you're seeing
misinformation masquerading as news that
are telling us and actually the right we
have seen a lot of that recently how
about the last two years of Russia
coverage on CNN for example Michael
Cohen met secretly with Russian spies in
Prague John Donne juniors about to be
indicted the steel dossier is entirely
real they told us all of that and much
more all of it wrong and stupid totally
dishonest the New York Times The
Washington Post one poet sirs for what
turned out to be misinformation
masquerading his news last Saturday
would have been a perfect moment
actually to apologize for that debacle
and return the prizes they won but no
nobody apologized nobody returned to
Pulitzer instead they celebrated
themselves no surprise there that's what
they do
what was odd though was hearing them
talk about free speech the first remin
is in fact under ferocious attack really
more than any time in the last 50 years
at least and yet the people in that room
don't seem to notice
where were these same people last summer
when the big tech companies colluded to
silence broadcaster Alex Jones Alex
Jones she's bad
CNN literally led the effort to make him
be quiet Jeff Zucker doesn't agree with
Alex Jones as his political views
therefore he thinks Alex Jones shouldn't
be allowed to talk so sucker shut him up
by force did anyone at Saturday's dinner
mention any of that and where were they
when Facebook and Twitter blocked ads
supporting congresswoman Marsha
Blackburn because they criticized
abortion where were they when Tommy
Robinson went to prison in the UK for
having unfashionable views about
immigration where were they when James
day Moore got fired and then slandered
by Google for questioning the company's
diversity theology where were they when
Peter Fleming lost his job teaching in
Virginia because he wouldn't use male
pronouns to describe a female student
did any of the First Amendment defenders
hairs for the First Amendment they say
at the dinner on Saturday say a single
word about any of this of course they
didn't their job they say is to hold the
powerful to account but when given the
chance to push back against the truly
powerful the actually powerful that
we're not even kidding powerful Google
Amazon Facebook PayPal do they say
anything ever no of course not they suck
up every single time they suck up to
power because that's who they are
dutiful toadies to the powerful
defending class interests and pretending
it is principled fine that's who they
are just don't lecture us about speech
please